[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - "MAYBE THIS TIME"]
(SINGING) Maybe this
time I'll be lucky.
Maybe this time he'll stay.
Maybe this time, for the first
time, love won't hurry away.
He will hold me fast.
I'll be home at last.
Not a loser anymore like the
last time and the time before.
Everybody loves a winner.
So nobody loved me.
(TALKING) I call
singing my first language.
Our currency is being open
and being open and available
to our emotions.
If you're closed
off as a person,
how are you going to be a
performer to get out there
and, you know, show love or
show agony or show despair?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Listen, make sure I'm
listening to the person I'm
up there on stage with, because
if you're truly listening,
then that'll force you
to be in the moment.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[MUSIC - "GOD BLESS THE CHILD"]
(SINGING) Yes, the strong gets
more while the weak ones fade.
Empty pockets don't
ever make the grade.
Mama may have.
Papa may have.
But God bless the child
that's got his own.
That's got his own.
(TALKING) Evolution is very
important to me as an artist.
Usually, if I'm scared of
it, I know I have to do it.
I will be a better
actress, a better artist.
It doesn't necessarily
mean that I will succeed.
But will I have
grown as a result?
[MUSIC - "BESS YOU IS MY WOMAN"]
(SINGING) From this minute, I'm
telling you, I keep this vow.
Oh my Bessie, we is happy now.
We is one now.
APPLAUSE]
Good afternoon.
I'm Philip Khoury.
And it is my great pleasure
to welcome all of you
to the 2018 Eugene McDermott
Award in the Arts Celebration--
celebration of the
extraordinary Audra McDonald.
And if any of you were at
Symphony Hall last night
and had the privilege
of seeing and listening
to Audra McDonald, you'll know
just how extraordinary she is.
First, I want to recognize Mary
McDermott-Cook who is with us
this evening.
Mary McDermott-Cook is the
president of the Eugene
McDermott Foundation.
She has been an
inspiration to all of us
at MIT for her great
support and in support
of her remarkable mother,
Margaret McDermott.
Margaret McDermott
is the individual
who created this
award 44 years ago.
And it has been a
thriving award throughout.
And Margaret
couldn't be with us,
but Mary is always with us,
here representing her mother
and also here with members
of friends and members
of the McDermott family.
So we're just delighted, Mary,
for your tremendous support,
and we wish Margaret
were here with us.
And I know you'll wish her,
all of us, the best for her.
Now as associate provost
with responsibility
for the arts at MIT,
I'm reminded every day
of the importance the arts are
to the pursuit of excellence
at this great
institution of ours.
Our unparalleled
public art collection
is one example but also
the concerts, the plays,
the exhibitions,
the installations
put on by our performing and
visual artists on our faculty
and among our students,
not just for this campus,
but for the world.
Our students who
mainly come here
to study science
and engineering also
partake and participate
in the arts fully.
Nearly half of all
undergraduates at MIT,
for example, choose to take a
class in the performing arts
each academic year.
That is one reason it is
felt so appropriate to have
had Audra McDonald in
our midst and especially
for our vocal students to have
had the opportunity to perform
and be coached by her.
And she paid tribute
to them last night
in remarkable ways,
which we'll never forget.
Now Audra McDonald is one of the
most accomplished actor-singers
of the American musical theater.
Of course, MIT is
not the only one who
has noticed her over the years.
We're not the last, but
we aren't the first.
You could call Audra a
serial award winner--
six Tonys, two Grammys,
an Emmy, a National Medal
for the Arts from President
Obama, and much more.
I should make clear that she has
earned the McDermott Award not
for a single work or for
lifetime achievement,
but for certain
qualities that reflect
MIT'S values and ideals.
First, her commitment
to risk taking,
for embracing and mastering
the most challenging roles,
especially, as she said,
those roles that scare her.
As one critic wrote,
she immerses herself
in roles with such
unrelenting fortitude
that it simply knocks you out.
A second quality is Audra
McDonald's versatility,
which reveals equally
well in performing
musical theater, in The
Great American Songbook,
in Shakespeare, and most
recently in network television.
And a third quality
is her ability
to connect creative minds
across disciplines-- something
that we are totally
committed to at MIT.
She commented, upon
accepting our invitation
to receive the McDermott
Award, "My greatest hope
is that art helps
us, as a society,
to find common ground--
to create, dialogue, and
to understand each other
in new and meaningful ways."
Now we're thrilled that
Audra McDonald's colleague
and friend, Oskar Eustis,
has joined her today
to speak with us.
He has been artistic director of
the Public Theater of New York
since 2005 and is a professor
of dramatic arts, writing,
and public policy at
New York University.
The Public Theater
arguably has done
more to nurture America's
best writers and directors
and actors than any
other institution
as well as to
democratize theater
by expanding the roles,
participants, and art
forms associated with it.
These days, the transformation
can be summed up
by mentioning one show--
one word-- Hamilton, which
premiered there at the Public
Theater in early 2015.
But the innovation and
expansion of the performing arts
that have characterized
Oskar Eustis's leadership
of the Public Theater have
been in progress for years
now and, no doubt, will
continue to transform theater
in the United States and beyond.
Audra McDonald appeared in
the Public Theater's 2004
production of Henry IV and
in Twelfth Night in 2009.
And I'm certain
Audra and Oskar have
much more than these
productions in common
when it comes to their
vision for theater
and for the contributions
the arts make to society.
I know they do.
Together, Audra McDonald
and Oskar Eustis
will discuss some of the
highlights of her career,
how theatrical revivals reflect
the times, and the evolution
of social attitudes and
cultural experiences
and how theater has evolved to
become more inclusive and more
representative of
contemporary diversity.
Please join me in welcoming
Audra McDonald and Oskar
Eustis.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
I really, really [INAUDIBLE]
You are spectacular.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
[INAUDIBLE]
Thank you so much, Philip.
[APPLAUSE]
Audra, I think we should get the
formalities out of the way.
OK.
We're talking today to
the greatest singing
actress in the history
of the American theater.
[CHEERING]
And--sorry, but it's true--
and the thing that we're
going to be exploring today
is we're going to try figure out
a little about how she does it,
so we can imitate it?
No.
Just so we can
appreciate a little more.
And I'd love to start--
this is a research institution--
and I'd love to
start with Lady Day.
OK.
Because your performance
in Lady Day was,
I thought, absolutely
miraculous, not only
the tremendous spiritual
and emotional depth
you brought, but also the
transformation of your voice.
It was uncanny,
deeply disturbing.
How do you understand
that about Billie Holiday?
Well, you know, I was
always a terrible student.
I was never good at
doing my homework on time
and doing it thoroughly.
But I was always a
good student when
it came to researching roles
and my work in the theater.
And with Billie Holiday, I
researched her into oblivion.
I mean, I not only read
every book I could about her,
I dug up every audio interview
I could find of her speaking.
I mean, she there
was an interview
she did with Mike Wallace.
There were certain
other radio programs
in Amsterdam and in Sweden
as well as in the States.
There's a lot of audio
recordings from rehearsals
she had with her band when
she was just at Jimmy Rowles's
apartment, her--
Where do you find
those recordings?
All over the place-- on the
internet, the Dark Web--
No, not the Dark Web.
[LAUGHTER]
A lot of places
in a lot of books
that I read would make mention--
Yeah, would give links.
- -of where to find them.
And it was very interesting with
those particular recordings,
especially the ones where she
was rehearsing with her band,
is you'd hear the interviews of
her with Mike Wallace and then
her very off-guard with her
band and hear the difference,
not only in lucidity--
depending on how drunk
she was or wherever
her mental state was--
but she was also an
incredible raconteur.
She was very funny when
she would tell stories.
She was very good at
imitating people as well.
So I did all of that aural
research-- of course,
all of her recordings, her
vocal recordings, her singing--
and then I interviewed
everybody I
could find that was still
alive that knew her,
that spent time with her.
Wow.
I talked to Dr.
Maya Angelou, who
had spent some time with her.
I spoke to some of
her old pianists.
I spent time with her godson.
And you just asked them
anecdotes or stories.
Everything.
And as the show was running,
more and more people
would come to see the show
that had spent time with her.
So people would come
backstage and bring me
little bits and pieces of
her through stories they had.
One woman whose father ran and
a dive nightclub somewhere,
and she was charged with going
to pick up Billie Holiday
and bring her to the
club to do the show,
and she told me the story of
how we had to stop and get
a big, old bottle of--
I think it was-- gin.
And she had drank half of it by
the time they got to the club.
And it was only like
a 20-minute drive.
[LAUGHTER]
So people would bring me
bits and pieces of her.
And then finding
her actual voice,
I realized, the more I listened
to the audio recordings
of her speaking,
the more I realized
that she sounded and
had a cadence quite
a bit like my grandmother--
my paternal grandmother.
And as a child, I used to--
I mean, I did it even as an
adult until she passed away.
My mom's here.
My mom will remember this.
I used to imitate my
grandmother and all
of her daughters, my
aunts, to their faces,
because I just thought it
was funny to imitate them.
And sometimes they
thought it was funny,
and sometimes they would
tell me to be quiet.
But I used to imitate
Nana all the time.
And I realized one day, in
listening to Billie Holiday,
I was like, she
speaks like Nana.
Oh, my goodness, Billie
Holiday sounds like Nana.
So I started imitating Nana,
and that's how I found Billie.
Oh, my God.
That's how I found the
vocal quality for Billie.
So in some ways, I
thank my grandmother,
because she was my conduit--
That's extraordinary.
- -get through to Billie.
But I have to ask, in
addition to your grandmother
and the research, so much
about Billie Holiday was
affected by her drug
dependency and substance abuse.
And when I watched
you on stage, it
felt like I was watching
somebody who understood that
really much more deeply than
your career could have allowed
you to understand that.
So--
Well, I mean, I
did the research--
not--
[LAUGHTER]
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
News flash--
I have never done heroin.
We've got the headline tomorrow.
No, no, no.
No, no, no, no.
I did not actually do heroin.
However, I did the research.
We talked to heroin
addict survivors.
We talked to--
I say "we," I mean me and
Lonny Price, my director,
who sort of brought the
project to me and held my hand
the whole way through--
we looked at lots of
footage of people,
not only under the
influence, but people
who had been through it and
lived to tell the story.
We talked to some
methadone addicts.
Wow.
And so we did all that research.
I also drank really heavily one
night and tried to do as much
of the play as I could--
not on stage, but just at home.
I didn't get very far.
But I got the
feeling of what that
was like to work through and try
and function through that fog.
And I talked to doctors too
just to get an idea of what
the body is going through--
What would have
happened to her body.
- -what happens to the body.
And also, it's a
very specific time
when the play takes place--
four months before Billie
Holiday passed away.
So she was dealing with very
specific medical issues.
She was quite swollen.
She was not eating
really at all.
Her legs and her ankles
were completely swollen.
Her stomach was very
distended-- all of that.
So I had all of
that as reference.
So it's like putting on big, hes
and then trying to function
and walk through life.
So that helped me
with the physicality.
And all of that, I
feel like, makes sense
in terms of what I saw
in your performance.
What I also saw was an emotional
rawness that was breathtaking.
It made me feel
so self-conscious almost to be
watching somebody that--
how do you do that eight times
a w-- did you do it eight times
a week or seven?
I did it eight times
a week in London.
I only did it seven
times a week on Broadway.
I did it eight times a week
in London, and I had a seven-,
eight-month-old baby with me.
So that helped the
whole fatigue--
Sand bag, sand bag.
- -aspect of it.
That was quite real.
But, of course, the
emotional open, sometime,
is characteristic of your work.
It's a thing.
Yeah, you know, it's
interesting when a lot of times
reporters will ask me or someone
is interviewing will ask me,
"What did you learn
about Billie Holiday
that you didn't know that
surprised you the most?"
And I think what
surprised me the most--
and this is going to
sound odd, and I'm
realizing it as I'm saying it--
what surprised me
the most, but maybe
unlocked a key to
everything else
making sense about
Billie Holiday,
was how much she wanted
children and how much
she wanted to be a mother.
More than anything in the
world, she wanted that.
She wanted family.
She didn't really have it.
And she wanted it
more than anything.
She tried to adopt twice and
was obviously turned down.
Was devastated by that.
And so a lot of the sort
of loneliness and sadness
that she felt-- and especially
because I am a mother.
I do have that joy and
that blessing in my life--
I was able to tap into
what that would be like.
This woman wanted that so
desperately and didn't have it.
And for some reason, that
just kind of was the key
into the bottom of
her sadness for me.
She shrugs
as if that's-- so what
you've described it is
a level of research into her,
into her medical condition,
into the people knew her, into
the spiritual heart of her,
and into your
grandmother's voice.
And part of
what strikes me is what
an enormous amount
of work that is that
is not happening just
in the rehearsal hall.
It's happening as you're
creating the part.
Yeah, yeah, I mean, that's
the life of an actor.
I did an interview with
one of the MIT students--
a great girl who I've
spent a bit of time
with in my residency
here-- named Talia.
She has a little video series
called Tea with Teachers.
And so we were just recording
that, and we had some tea.
And she had little
Reese's peanut butter cups
out there for me too,
which made me very happy.
But I was telling her that
being an artist, especially
when you're being an actor,
the research is just as intense
as if you were researching about
nano molecular archaeological
hoo-ha.
Hoo-ha, yeah.
I've looked into that too.
[LAUGHTER]
But you have to be that
thorough with your research.
I mean.
If you're going to go out
there and be this person,
you have to know everything that
you possibly can about them.
We are not going
to focus solely on
your drug-addicted characters.
However--
However, you rather famously--
your Bess-- both the addiction
felt realer than any Bess
that I had ever read
about or seen before.
But you are also struggling,
not with a real person,
but with a fictional character
with a very problematized
history.
Can you talk-- because
you're reviving
what is, at one and
the same moment,
a classic and yet a very
problematic perspective
on African-American life.
I wonder if you could talk
about what that was like.
Well, in portraying Bess--
Porgy and Bess was
a musical or opera,
depending on how you
want to refer to it,
and I know there's a
debate about that all
the time about what it is--
that I had loved deeply
and was quite obsessed with
and knew from top to bottom.
I could sing every single part
in my dorm room at Juilliard,
and a lot of times, I
would at night to sort of
put on the record--
the record, yes, it was
a record at that point--
and sing through
the whole thing.
So when I
was offered the part, I
knew I wanted to,
not only research
the opera and everything as
much as I possibly could,
but I wanted to really make
sure I understood the genesis
for who this woman was.
And so I went back to the book.
I went back to the
source material, which
is the book by DuBose Heyward.
And I really studied
this character.
And there were certain things in
the book that obviously didn't
make it into the libretto,
which were interesting to me--
the fact that she had a
huge scar on her face,
and that's one of the first ways
that DuBose Heyward describes
her.
She's this statuesque
woman, buxom woman,
a little bit past her prime,
humongous scar on her face,
which told a story.
I mean, I think he even
refers to it in that way,
that there is a story there.
And so I was trying to just
get right down to the bones.
And then I did the
research about what
it was like to be an
African-American woman
at that time and what
your choices were.
Your choices-- they
were very limited.
Your choices were-- you had to
have some source of income--
so either you were working,
or you had a husband
that was supporting you.
I mean, Mom, am I--
in those days.
I mean, not that you
were there in those days.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm just saying.
No, you're too young for that.
But for African-American
women during the time,
there were just
weren't many options.
So if you didn't have either one
of those things, a lot of them
had to turn toward either
prostitution or men
that would support
them in whatever way
or whatever contract that
they could come up with.
And once again, I
studied the life.
I went to Catfish Row
in South Carolina.
I went to the cabin
where Gershwin
wrote most of Porgy and Bess.
And then obviously, there was
the political ramifications.
were doing
it here in Cambridge.
And the New York
Times did the story.
And then Mr. Sondheim
wrote a letter and about--
Not his sunniest side.
And it's because everybody is
very passionate about Porgy
and Bess.
And I think Gershwin
absolutely approached this
with love and with as much
as he could give to it
and as much as he could
possibly understand.
But he was still
writing about a culture
that he may have studied as
much as he possibly could, but--
It wasn't his.
- -there was a part of
it that wasn't his,
that he was not ever
going to get into.
And so, for us, it was very
important to make sure that we
infused it in a way that had--
I don't want
to choose the wrong word--
but the understanding and the
nobility and pride of that
people--
That's the right word.
- -that perhaps there was no
possible way that Gershwin
could have put into
those characters,
because that's not a
culture he came from.
Right, right.
Even though I think he
wrote them with love.
So can you talk--
just famously, here
in Cambridge, Bess
rejects the drugs at the end?
Yes, and then by the time
you came to New York,
you'd changed that decision.
Yes.
And I mean, can you just
talk a little bit about that?
Sorry if I'm--
No, no, no.
I mean, I think, with
Diane Paulus, who is--
Brilliant, brilliant, brilliant.
- -a brilliant director
and in charge of the ART.
We had been given this charge
from the estate to--
all right, dust it off, see
what you can find there.
And so I think we were
throwing everything at the wall
and seeing what worked.
So Diane wanted to
try it this way.
And directors who have
worked with me have, I think,
lovingly and honestly
said that I'm not--
OK, I guess I'm
difficult to work with.
I'm going to say it.
[LAUGHTER]
I will try something.
I've heard "intense."
Intense.
I've heard demanding.
I haven't heard difficult.
I will try anything once.
And I will try.
And if you cannot convince me
of an organic and truthful why,
it's never going to work on me.
Right, right.
I won't be able to execute it.
I won't be able to do it.
And as many times
as I tried to do it,
rejecting the drugs in
the end, it wouldn't work.
She'd watch the
show and come back
and go, "OK, can
you try--" And it
wasn't that I wouldn't do it.
It's just that I couldn't
find the why anywhere
within my bones.
And I guess that makes me a
bit difficult to work with.
No, it doesn't.
And so in the end,
Diane and I decided,
OK, let's try it this way.
And then we tried it that way.
And it was like,
OK, there she is.
There you are.
And now, Audra,
it's making sense,
and it's ringing true
organically for you
in your performance.
And it also, frankly, in New
York, it was heartbreaking.
It was devastating.
And that very question that you
have ennobling the character--
weirdly enough, she
was more ennobled
falling than she was
resisting, because you
could feel the size of the
spirit that was going under.
It was just, I
thought, extraordinary.
It's interesting to have
played those characters back
to back-- to play Bess and then
to have played Billie Holiday.
James Baldwin wrote about
Billie Holiday's death right
around the time of her death.
Seeing her in that
cafe [INAUDIBLE]..
Yes, and then he wrote about
seeing her in the hospital.
And she said that she would die
if people would only leave her
alone.
But he also said I am
told-- this is awful--
but he said, "I am told
that Dorothy Dandridge is
an actress.
I have yet to see
that be the case."
This is what James
Baldwin said, because he
felt and a lot of people felt
that Billie Holiday should have
played that part,
that it should have
been given to Billie Holiday,
that she knew who Bess was.
She understood that.
She understood everything about
what Bess was going through.
That's really astonishing.
It was her life.
And that Bess should
have played that role.
And James Baldwin
was a friend of Bess.
And therefore, that's why he
was a bit scathing in saying
that about Dorothy Dandridge.
Wow.
I mean, the image
of her playing--
Yeah.
But speaking of-- well, you had
a lighter role in the show--
but Carousel, which
is coming back to us
and which was the first
time that I and most
of the world actually fully
realized how great you were
is in that production, which
you were just amazing in.
But Carousel is
also problematic.
I mean, we had a little
celebration of wife beating.
And sometimes, it
doesn't feel like--
so what does it
feel like to hear
it's coming back to Broadway.
Yeah, to see it now--
it's interesting.
When we were doing
carousel back in 1994,
one of the nights that
we were doing the show
was the night of the infamous
slow speed white Bronco chase
down the 405--
Wow.
- -with OJ Simpson on the run.
And it was so interesting.
We were all just--
our hackles were all
up as we were getting
ready to start the show that
night, because everybody
was watching what was happening
in these places we got to go.
And then to step into this
world where you've got
this domestic abuse situation.
And it's interesting.
I think what I was saying to--
Oskar and I were talking about
this a little bit backstage.
With that show, just
because a character says
something doesn't necessarily
mean that it's true.
Right.
And so I think, for some
people that are saying,
"Why are they doing
Carousel again?
It's about a wife
beater," and then, "She
seems to think it's fine.
And she says it's fine."
Why are we doing that
in the age of me too,
and how could you do that?"
This is how certain people
in this particular situation
are dealing with it.
Just because Julie says, "Yes,
it's possible for somebody
to hit you, hit you really
hard, and it not hurt at all."
Julie can say that and
not necessarily mean it
but realize she has
to say something
to this child who has had
this emotional experience.
And when we did Carousel,
to watch Sally Murphy,
the girl who played that part,
when she said those words,
or even when she's saying,
"What's the use of wondering?"
It wasn't just, (SINGING)
"Yeah, he beats me,
and it's really
great, and I love him.
Here's is a high note!"
She didn't sing it
like that at all.
She sang it from a place
of anger at herself.
She sang it from a place of
just being resigned that this
is the life that I have chosen.
And she sang it from a
place of, and in the end,
throughout all of it,
I still love this man.
And I can't figure out why.
But I do.
And that's real.
And that's real today for women
and certain people in 2018.
And so that's why,
I think, Carousel
can still have all the
relevance that it needs to have.
And I don't think you
need to shy away from it.
I mean, you can shine a light
on it all, but that once again,
will show us-- like theater
is brilliant at doing--
is how you one person's
experience of something--
What you're
describing, what's so
interesting is that it's
not shying away from--
Not shying away from it.
- -and trying to polish up--
No, no, no, no. --how ugly
the emotion is, but it
is creating perspective on it.
Perspective, yeah.
It is saying we don't
have to simply buy
this as God's point of view.
No.
We see it in context.
Yes, and then you can really
weep for that person, saying
"Oh, God," that you could
save yourself or that someone
could save you from that.
You know, it's interesting.
That's exactly
what you're saying
about Bess in
Porgy and Bess too,
which is that the
way that you alter it
is not by making
a happy ending--
No.
- -is not by changing
how dark it is,
but by letting us
understand how dark it is--
Exactly.
- -letting us understand from--
Didn't they say that's
how the Greeks got
it right in terms of why we have
theater in the first place is
because we needed to see people
up there killing their fathers,
having sex with their mothers,
whatever, going through all
these huge emotional
things, because it gave us
more understanding of ourselves
and gave us the catharsis
that we needed.
Exactly right.
And what was the
quote that you were--
She's setting me up now.
I'm not.
In a good way.
She's being-- No, I was
just saying that Aristotle--
Aristotle, yeah.
- -in the poetics, he has
this famous statement that,
"Tragedy shows people
as better than they are,
and comedy shows people
as worse than they are."
And the way I've
always interpreted
that is not as, say, the
New Classical French did,
that that meant that tragedy
had to be about nobility.
It meant that tragedy
was about people
who were more willing to
follow through on their desires
and face the consequences of
their desires than we are.
And comedy is about
people who are
more desperate to avoid the
consequences of their desires
than we are.
And I think this is
exactly what you're
describing for Bess and
for Julie in Carousel.
So Audra, I promised
that we were
going to at least try to
figure out a little bit of how
you can do this.
How did you start doing this?
I mean, your mother's here.
We could ask her.
But where did you come from?
How did this--
Where did I come from?
I came from my mom.
That's my mom, Anna
McDonald, there.
I came from her.
[APPLAUSE]
Yes, yes.
And actually, on behalf of
the American Theater,
actually, let me take this
moment to formally thank you
for one of the greatest gifts
the American Theater has ever
had, and we know Audra
wouldn't exist without you.
So thank you.
So how did you start?
Did they know you
were an actress?
Every day from age two on,
our daughter was an actress.
Wow, from age two on,
Audra was an actress.
Very animated, very emotional
about little things,
deathly afraid of the
thunder, everything like that.
Everything affected me
in a very big, big way.
Animated and emotional
about little things--
I'm sure they didn't
seem little to Audra.
Huge to me.
Deathly afraid of thunder.
Very.
I was very afraid of thunder.
So how did you find the theater?
[LAUGHTER]
When Audra was about
eight or nine years old,
my husband and I went
to celebrate our wedding
anniversary--
[INAUDIBLE]
When Audra was about
eight or nine years old,
my husband and I went
to celebrate our wedding
anniversary at a
local dinner theater.
And before the
actual presentation,
there was a group of young
people who did a cabaret show.
And they called them
The Junior Company.
And after they performed-- and
we had been dealing with one
of Audra's
performances at home--
[LAUGHTER]
- -and at
the time, my husband
was taking some child
psychology classes.
[LAUGHTER]
He really was.
And he asked his
professor, he said,
"I've got this kid
at home who just--
I mean, it's like she's
a parade every day."
And he said, "You need
to channel that energy."
Well, we were told, you might
want to put her on Ritalin,
get her into
something like that,
because they called
her hyperactive.
And when we were sitting and saw
all of these kids performing,
we looked at each
other and said, "Audra.
Let's get her up there."
And that's what
we decided to do.
We let her audition,
and she became
a part of The Junior
Company and had an outlet
for all of that energy.
Oh, that's so interesting.
[APPLAUSE]
And did you know
right away that this was what
you were going to keep doing?
Yeah.
So how old were you?
Eight or nine, nine.
Wow.
Eight.
Yeah, eight.
Yeah.
And what did it feel like?
I felt calm, which is crazy.
No, no, no.
I get it.
But it's exactly what
my mom described.
I had an outlet.
I mean, if I was going to
freak out about the thunder,
I could freak out about the
thunder while singing on stage
and get paid $10
a week to do it,
which is my salary at the time.
I was thrilled with
the $10 a week.
But yeah, and so for
me, I had an outlet.
I felt normal.
I didn't feel crazy.
For me, my memory is
that I didn't feel
like I was a problem anymore.
And that maybe-- and I'm
sure there were more problems
to come-- but in the
sense that I had a place
to go and be myself.
It was like it just fit.
It was like that
piece in a puzzle.
There was an opening in
the middle of a puzzle,
and they just plugged me in.
It's like, oh, OK.
OK, that's why I
have the piece that
looks like this
and this piece has
my heart that beats
really big like that,
because it fits in here.
What's funny about that is
that you're the greatest
performer of our
generation, and I'm just
a guy who runs a theater.
And that's exactly how
I felt about the theater
when I went there.
I felt normal for first time.
I didn't feel like I was
too loud for the first time.
I didn't feel like I cried
too easily for the first time.
Yes, yes.
I didn't feel like
I laughed too much.
Yes.
All of this stuff that--
and I was in
Minnesota, and boy--
[LAUGHTER]
Fresno, you know.
Yeah.
And the crying too
much thing for a boy--
not good.
[INAUDIBLE]
you found your tribe.
Found your tribe.
And it's the beautiful
thing about the theater
is that I've never
found anything
that I care about that I
can't bring into the theater--
any subject I'm interested
in, any feeling I
have, there's a place to--
There is a space for it all.
There's a place to put it.
Yeah, absolutely.
And so as you started growing
up and went off to that very
non-competitive
place, Juilliard,
that very sort of accepting,
almost hippie school--
[LAUGHTER] how
did that work out?
Oh, great.
Great.
What did it feel--
because once you there,
that's like serious
professional.
Yes.
I mean, Juilliard,
it seems like it
should have been just like
right along the trajectory.
But for me, I auditioned for
a couple of different schools,
and I think I got into
UCLA and UC-Irvine and NYU.
And my mom took me to New York
to audition for Juilliard.
And I just blew the audition,
because I didn't really
know about opera.
And I didn't think that
that's where I would end up.
But I just thought,
let me audition
for the vocal department,
because I think
my singing is my strong point.
But I was thinking that I'd
end up in the musical theater
department.
There's no musical theater
department at Juilliard.
But I didn't figure
that part out.
So I went ahead,
and I auditioned.
And I riffed at the end of
"Deh vieni, non tardar,"
which is Mozart's aria
from "Le Nozze di Figaro."
You don't riff with
Mozart, but I did.
I said I was a
mezzo-soprano, even though I
was singing a soprano aria.
I was like, yeah, I'm a mezzo.
And then I sang, and they're
like, "No, you're not.
What are you doing?"
I just was terrible.
And they accepted me,
so it was like, well,
Juilliard accepted me.
I better say yes, especially
before they figure out
that they made a mistake.
So I just went.
And I just thought,
well, I'm in New York.
I'm close to Broadway.
My address was on Broadway.
Here we go.
This is going to happen.
And what I thought was this
trajectory felt like, [GRUNTS],
because I was in the vocal
performance, which meant you
study your languages, you study
your Italian, your French,
your German, your Spanish,
your English diction.
You take literature
and material classes.
You take ear-training classes.
You take all the
classical classes
you need to be a
classical musician.
You have your voice
lessons, and that's it.
Wow.
And so all of a
sudden, I felt like I
made a wrong turn somewhere.
And I am never going to
get to Broadway, a, and b,
I hate what I sound like.
I don't want to be
an opera singer.
I don't like singing like this.
That's not what I want to do.
What's happening?
It was a very
confusing time for me.
Wow, Audra.
But I ended up finding out that
I did have an operatic sound.
And Juilliard helped me discover
a whole section of my voice
that I didn't know existed.
And so, once I was able to
figure all that out and then
come back around
the bend, I mean,
and maybe my path was
this way, and I just
thought it was this way.
I don't know.
Yeah, or it's just life
was happening to you--
Life was happening.
- -and it was letting
you figure things out.
Yeah, and I was in the
exact right place, but--
How strange.
- -the whole time
I was there, you
could have never
convinced me that I was.
Yeah.
I mean, partly is that
your mistake started
at the audition of thinking
that your voice was
your strong suit.
I want to point
out that Audra is
the only actor in
American history
who has won every possible
Tony award for Best Supporting
Actress, Best Lead Actress,
Best Actress in a Musical,
and Best Supporting
Actress in a Musical.
I don't think your voice
is your only strong point.
I mean, the jury's
in on the one.
It was right
in the middle of there
that you went to
Carousel, right?
Or right after Juilliard?
Right after.
How did that happen?
I had a breakdown
while I was at Juilliard.
I had a bit of a mental break.
I had a suicide attempt.
I ended up in a mental
hospital for a month.
And I took a semester and a
little more off from school.
And then I went back--
all supported by the school.
They were very supportive.
And it's nothing that I hide.
I talk about it quite
openly, especially because I
know a lot of young
people listen to me
and follow me and
follow my career.
And I want them to know
that there is a way through.
And so I went back.
And while I was there,
I got the opportunity
to audition for Carousel.
No, no, no.
I got the opportunity to
audition for The Secret Garden,
which was going on tour.
And I auditioned.
And they accepted me.
And I had to ask permission
to leave school to do it.
And they said,
"Yeah, go do that.
We think that's probably where
you're going to end up anyway,
so we're fine with it."
So they let me go.
Wow, wow, wow.
And they said, you can
defer and just graduate
when you're done with that.
So I came back, graduated, went
back out on the road with that,
and then auditioned for
Carousel and got Carousel.
A year and two
months after I graduated,
I opened in Carousel across the
street at the Vivian Beaumont.
And I could literally,
from the Vivian Beaumont,
look up and see my school
and some of my classmates
that had gone on to get
their master's degrees.
They were much smarter
than I was and whatnot.
That's pretty magical.
It was very magical.
That's pretty extra--
Very lucky.
I mean, there in
the Beaumont during Carousel,
did it feel like you were now
on the path you needed to be on?
Did it feel right?
Yes, as much as one can
be present at 23, yes.
No, no, no.
Do you know in that sense
that life is still happening?
It's a confusing time.
And I was a spastic 23-year-old.
But yes, in that sense I felt
like, yes, I'm on Broadway.
But I'm singing
Rodgers and Hammerstein
with a pretty decent
technique in a classical way
that I wouldn't
have known how to do
had I not going to Juilliard.
First off, I just
want thank you for talking
about psychological
difficulties.
That's a big deal, Audra.
It's something that an awful
lot of people don't talk about.
[APPLAUSE]
And again,
it's partly also the
way you talk about it.
It's just so clear that the
difficulties you had you
have integrated and
recovered from and built
not only an extraordinary career
but an extraordinary life,
because I do know
her a little bit.
And I will say that Audra is
proof of one of those things
that the really greatest artists
are the best people I know.
There are some just below that
level who can be real jerks.
[LAUGHTER]
But seriously, really the
greatest artists I know
are just--
they are that great
partly because
of the size of their heart and
the integration of the spirit.
So thank you for that.
And maybe we could take just
a minute to talk about--
I know you're really
involved in Covenant House.
I know you've become
more of an activist.
I think that's due to
a couple of things.
I'm very aware of how lucky I am
and the opportunities that I've
been given and the great
amount of luck and blessings
I've had in my life.
And I've always been vocal.
I guess that's a good word
to use about everything.
Thunderstorms.
Yeah, thunderstorms, whatnot.
But I think activism really
started in earnest when I--
I mean, I was certainly raised
in a very democratic household.
And I know my mom's
brother, Uncle Lloyd,
did the sit-ins and stuff,
right, during the '60s?
Yeah, because they're
from the Washington DC
and Virginia area.
And so that was
sort of in my blood.
And on my dad's side
of the family as well.
My great uncle was an activist.
He actually worked with
Bobby Kennedy for a second.
Bobby Kennedy, I think, was to
meet with him the day after he
was assassinated, Uncle Jesse.
At any rate, all that to
say that it's in my blood.
And then I met my
wonderful husband, Will,
who is also here.
And he's an actor.
[APPLAUSE]
So we blended
our families, and we're
raising our kids together.
And Will was working
with you on Hair.
Will was starring in Hair.
And Oskar was producing
that for the Public
and then on Broadway right
in the midst of the marriage
equality movement.
And Oskar and Will and all
the rest of Will's cast
got very involved with that.
And it was certainly
something that I
was very passionate
about, being someone
who actually believes in
marriage equality and LGBTQ
rights.
And we got very much, not caught
up, but just very involved
with that movement
and did the march
and did rallies
in New York City.
And I went up to Albany to
lobby members of our Congress
up there.
And then I was
looking for a place
to donate money on
opening night of Lady Day
instead of giving
opening gifts to my cast,
because the cast
consisted of me the band
and the dog, the chihuahua.
What do I get the chihuahua
for opening night?
So I decided I would do
a donation somewhere.
And I thought about
the Covenant House,
which a lot of Broadway
folks had done some work for.
And the Covenant House a
shelter for homeless youth.
And there's homes in Canada
and in the United States
and in Latin America as well.
And so I went down to do a
donation in between shows,
because Billie Holiday
was homeless for a lot
of her childhood and
had a rough childhood.
So I thought this
seems appropriate.
So I went in, and I had a check.
And it was in between
shows on a Saturday.
And there was two sort
of security guards there.
And they said, "We don't have
anybody here today-- it's
the weekend-- who
can take a check.
We're not allowed to do that.
So we'll call around and see.
So just have a seat."
So while I was waiting,
I saw a young man
come in off the street
with a trash bag.
And he-- I don't know--
looked about 15 maybe 16.
And he looked so world weary
and exhausted and frightened and
defensive.
And these two security
guards had also
been kind of flirting with me.
And they had been
saying, "You know
you could write a check to
me," and all this stuff.
And so I was, you
know, whatever.
And then they saw
this kid come in,
and they just leapt into action
like they were Batman and Robin
and just took this kid and
said, "Hey, you're all right.
Come on, man.
We got you.
You're OK.
What you need?
Sit down.
You want something to drink?
You want something to eat?
We're going to take care of you.
We got you."
And my heart blew wide open.
And so I got very involved
with the Covenant House
and am now on an International
Board of Directors
of the Covenant House.
And in fact, my plan is to share
part of the McDermott Award
with the Covenant House to
help some of those kids there.
[APPLAUSE]
But anyway, so that's life.
Thank you.
It's because, as
Michelle Obama said,
"Once you walk through
that door of opportunity,
you don't slam that
door behind you.
You reach backward and help
the next person through."
And it's just important.
And I know it's a way
that Will and I have
been trying to raise our kids.
And now we have our own little
17-month-old little monster
that we have now.
And if we can just
keep her out of jail.
She's a wild thing.
I don't know.
But we're teaching
them that they
have to be good
citizens of the world.
And they have to give back.
And so, as we learn it,
we're trying to teach it.
That's all.
And I just have
to take my moment
to say that also it is
such a joy to watch you
and Will together.
Will is a man and artist
I admire so, so much.
I've been so lucky to be
able to work with him.
And to watch that
you two guys are
able to make a life as actors
and as marriage together has
been just a beautiful thing.
So that's just [INAUDIBLE].
But before we take
a few questions,
I just have to let you know
that I have promised Audra
that I'm not going to use
this opportunity just get her
to sign up for shows for me.
If you would like to
use this opportunity--
[LAUGHTER] she didn't
say no to that.
Aside from everything
we're going to do together,
Audra, what do you want to do?
When you look ahead, what
are the things you'd still
like to try to be scared by?
Everything.
Seriously.
I mean, I say it all
the time, but it's true.
I just want to evolve as
an artist, as a person.
You got to make good use
of the time we're given.
And I don't want the
rest on my laurels.
I don't want to
be content with--
I'm grateful for the
success that I've had,
but I don't want to
go, "OK, that's it.
I'm done."
I want to evolve.
I want to be a better artist.
I want to be a better wife.
I want to be a better mother.
Because if you're not evolving--
I want to be a better
citizen of the world.
Maybe I'm
going to run for office.
I don't know.
I mean, I don't know.
[APPLAUSE]
I want to do better.
I know that's
grammatically not correct.
Sorry MIT.
I want to evolve.
OK, if you do that, you
have a dispensation.
You don't have to do any shows
for me if you run for office.
But other than that, you do.
Anyway, I'm not going to sum
up, because what instead we're
going to do is we're going
to give the audience a chance
to ask a few questions.
I think we have microphones.
Thank you.
Audra, Oskar, thanks so much.
So we'll open it up.
[APPLAUSE]
And Audra,
there is one alternative
if, in the evolution,
you might want
to come join our MIT faculty.
OK.
That too.
We can talk to our president.
We'd be honored.
So we have microphones.
And they're down here.
And try to come
up and maybe just,
if you would, if you have
a question, ask just one,
so we give some time to others.
Don't be shy either.
No one has any questions.
Please, anyone here?
Yes, please.
Thank you.
Hi.
Good.
OK, this is really wild.
You're like Loki.
You are like a huge
vocal role model for me--
Oh, thank you.
- -in trying to develop
my own unique voice.
And I really appreciate you.
Oh, gosh, I'm tearing up.
But basically-- sorry,
this is kind of weird.
I'm like short, but
the stairs are tall.
Anyways, so like I guess
every role for an actor--
I don't actually act--
I feel like every role is like
another life that you live.
And you can't really like do
that without having some growth
and change in yourself.
So my question is,
out of all the rules
you've ever played like
on stage or on screen,
which one has changed you the
most for better or for worse?
Between you
and Talia, man, I mean,
she asked the most
amazing questions.
I'm telling you.
Now you're getting me.
What has changed me the most?
OK, I'm going to answer
that in a different way.
I'm going to tell you the one
that was the hardest to play.
It was the hardest to find.
And that was Ruth in
A Raisin in the Sun.
And the reason why
it was the hardest
to find, because it was
the closest to me on paper.
And I realized
I was blocking, because
it was too close to me.
She was a mom.
She was an exhausted
wife, a mom.
And she said issues, was
dealing with a pregnancy and all
this stuff--
things that I really understood.
And I was the same age as her.
So I was blocked by her.
I was blocked, and
I once I realized
that I was blocked because
it was too close to me,
it was about learning to like--
so maybe that role changed me
the most, because it taught me
that I had to open up and go
even deeper and go to like,
what we were talking about
before-- like the third rail--
we were talking about going
to that third rail, which
is a scary place to be.
But it's where all the truth is.
And so that's the
one that taught me,
I think, to go super deep.
So that changed me in a good
way as an artist, I think.
A role that changed
me in a bad way--
I think my English
teacher in 11th grade
would say it's when I
played Ava Peron in Evita
at my dinner theater
that I grew up in.
Because I guess I became
a bit of a shit at school.
Because I was playing Evita at
night and then going to school
and being like, "What?
You want what from me?
I'm not doing my homework."
That was the worst one.
I was pretty bad.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Good luck with your career.
[APPLAUSE]
Hi.
And she's gone.
Thank you both for being here.
You're very, very articulate.
And my husband and I, who
are New Yorkers and partners
with The Public
Theater, have enjoyed
seeing you at Delacorte
and in other things.
But I can't resist
taking up the opening
to say, when are you
going to come back
to The Public Theater?
We'd love to see you again
at the Delacorte or downtown.
Oh, man, well, Will and I
both love the Delacorte.
We'd love to come back to--
I mean, anything in the public--
but the Delacorte for sure.
There's something so magical
about playing the Delacorte
and being out in the open and
doing Shakespeare or whatever
and then with the
lovely baby raccoons
coming up on stage
every once in a while.
During Twelfth Night, the baby
raccoons came up on stage.
And Anne Hathaway and I
thought that we were really
killing the audience.
They were just laughing.
We were like, oh,
we're nailing it!
We come off stage, and we're
like, "We nailed that scene!"
And the cast was like,
"No, the raccoons
had come on behind you."
But yes, any time that
Oskar will have us,
Will and I will come for sure.
That'll happen.
Thank you.
Well done.
That's your membership
dues for the year.
Hi.
OK, I'm going
to take a deep breath.
You've been a hero
of mine really
ever since I heard your voice.
I think there was a Leonard
Bernstein New York tribute
album.
And I heard you sing
"A Little Bit In Love,"
and I was more than
a little bit in love.
Oh, thank you.
And you were a hero
of mine in the way
you combined your classical
training with musical theater.
And it was just sort
of a bolt hearing
you talk about your
college experience
and sort of
struggling to combine
these and kind of
the different camps
that music departments go into.
And I struggled with that too.
And I ended up leaving
a music department.
But I guess, a, would you have
any advice for college students
maybe struggling with that now?
Or do you get the
sense that it's
a little better now that
it's not kind of broken up
in camps in this way?
Well, I can't speak to
every college department.
I do know that there have been
a lot of changes implemented
at Julliard since the
years that I've been there.
And they allow for the
younger vocal students
to have some acting classes.
Or they allow them to sing a
little bit of musical theater.
They give them
performance opportunities
now that were not available
to me in my generation there.
And that's, I think, made for
a healthier sort of learning
environment for these kids.
And what my advice to this
students has always been--
listen and learn as much as
you can, but trust your gut
and do not try to sound
like anybody else.
Try to sound like the best
version of you, but do not try
and imitate.
Do not try to sound
like anybody else.
And that is what will set
you apart from everybody else
is that you have your
own unique sound.
And once I learned
that, that's what sort
of kind of send me free.
And so that's what I say to my
students more than anything.
I don't know if it's helpful.
Yeah, thank you.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Hello.
Hi, 24 years ago, I
saw you in Carousel.
And it's an indelible memory.
And it was a
wonderful performance.
And I still remember
that so vividly.
And I'm going to remember
that until the day I die.
I really will.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Lizzie in 110 Degrees
in the Shade--
you're a very
high-octane person,
and Lizzie is a plain character.
What was your
process in deciding
how to present
this plainness when
it wasn't inherent in
the way you self-present?
Well, I think the interesting
thing about Lizzie
is she's not a plain character.
That's how everybody in her
life kept describing her to her.
And that's how she was sort of
branded within the community.
You're plain.
She talked a little too much.
She was too smart.
And so for me, it was--
I mean, in terms
of what she looked like, OK,
so I didn't wear any makeup in
the show or anything like that.
But I think Lizzie actually
was a high-octane person
with a lot of passion
and a lot of love to give
and a lot of dreams
and aspirations
that she kind of felt were
constantly being pushed down.
And so the struggle for
Lizzie is to truly believe,
and that's what Starbuck gives
her is that she helps her
to see that she is beautiful.
She is deserving of love.
She does have all
that within her.
So I think it's quite
actually the opposite is
that she was not that.
She was not that.
And the journey is discovering
that, that she's not that.
Well, I'm glad I have the album.
OK.
Hi.
So you've worked both
on stage and on screen,
but you've also had your stage
work recorded as with Lady
Day and the HBO recording.
And I was wondering
if you could just
speak a little bit to
that experience of taking
what's somewhat more
ephemeral in nature
as theatrical performances
are often described
and how it was like to do
that for a single recording
and what you think of kind of
recording theater in general?
Although that's a very touchy
topic for a lot of people.
I think it's very important.
For me-- maybe it's
just me being selfish--
there are performances that
we'll never have,
because, I mean,
I would have loved
to have seen Merman in Gypsy.
Can you imagine
opening night of Hamlet
with Burbage at
the Globe Theater.
I mean, we'd kill
for a tape of that.
I mean, I love that
Lincoln Center Library
archives all the shows now.
That's very important
that we have that history.
Speaking to the first part of
your question, we did Lady Day.
When we filmed it, we filmed
it at a kind of defunct cafe
in New Orleans that
we were able to sort
of turn into the nightclub.
And it was very difficult.
It was very difficult.
We did it over three
different nights.
And we did have audience
members come in,
because people would have
been in the audience.
So that's the realistic
sort of portrayal.
But it was very difficult,
because we also had 11 cameras.
And that's a very tiny space.
We had 11 cameras, and even like
when she would go off the stage
and go to the bar
and stuff, I was
having to kind of walk by and
over camera dollies and stuff
like that.
I had to
use different muscles.
And if we're being completely
honest, I haven't seen it.
Honestly, I haven't.
And I think it's
going to be years
before I'm able to
watch that performance,
because I don't like
watching myself on film.
And I know what I went through
in trying to stay focused
to get that performance.
So it would be uncomfortable
for me to watch.
But it's a very
tricky thing to do.
I don't think I
answered your question.
You absolutely did.
Thank you so much.
I mean, one thing I
will say about that
is, I am delighted that the
New York Library formats exist
and delighted that we have the
theater on tape collection.
And to me, it is an
academic research tool.
Yes.
I go up there to study stuff.
I don't ever feel like
I'm going up there
to have a complete
experience of a work of art.
I'm going up there, and
it's a historical record
of a work of art that
isn't there anymore.
Because, I mean,
my parochial view
is that the theater
is supposed to vanish.
That's the whole truth
of it, just like we do.
It vanishes.
But that doesn't mean that I
don't love having it on tape.
Absolutely.
Hi.
Hello.
Thank you.
You talked about thinking
and researching the roles,
but I'm curious about practice
and how you practice or maybe
rehearse in your field.
And what's different about
that than when you're standing
in the moment and performing?
Do you mean in terms of
like rehearsal process?
Yes.
Well, I mean, when you're
working on any show, I mean,
you rehearse usually
six to eight weeks.
And with a Broadway schedule,
you rehearse 10:00 to 6:00
every day, six days a week,
for six to eight weeks.
And then once you're
up and in previews,
before you officially open a
show, you do the show at night,
and you rehearse
during the day as well.
And aside from that, a
performer is like an athlete.
You still have to take
your voice lessons.
You have to keep yourself
in tip-top condition,
because our body
is our instrument.
And so Will and I both, we
still take voice lessons.
When I was doing
Shuffle Along, I
was having to learn how
to tap dance or remember
how to tap dance.
After 40 years of
not doing it, I
had to figure out
how to do that again.
So the training never stops.
You're constantly in training.
You had a second
part of the question.
What's it like then
once you stand on stage?
Here's the thing.
Once you get up
on stage, you then
have to throw it
all out the window.
That's the truth.
You throw it all out the window.
And you're forced
to be in the moment.
And I want to say you're
flying on blind faith and luck.
But you do have to throw
it all out the window
and then just go
down to your gut.
Do you want to do it?
No, but I think about it in an
athletic performative space.
You don't rehearse the
marathon in the same way
that you run the marathon.
That's true, but you train
for a marathon, don't you?
Yeah, absolutely.
Absolutely.
Thank you.
Hi.
One of my favorite plays
was Master Class with you.
I'm missing your signature.
I've been waiting 21, 22 years.
23 years.
But I do you have Zoe
Caldwell's signature
and just wondered if
you would consider
playing the part of Maria
Callas this time, or have you?
First of all, yes, I
will sign your poster.
I'm sorry I wasn't there
to sign it 22 years ago.
Shame on me.
And actually, that question
has been asked before,
if I would want to
play Maria Callas.
I think you would,
should, could.
It's an amazing role.
It's hard, because
there's a part of me that
would absolutely love to do it,
but there's a part of me that--
the performance by Zoe Caldwell,
who I named my first child
after, is so sacred
to me that I don't
know that I would
want to touch it,
because it's so sacred to me--
my relationship to
her, what she meant
to me, what that whole
experience meant to me,
and watching every
night her do it.
There's a part
of me that feels that it might
be sacrilegious to play her.
It's my own personal
things, so I don't know.
But it's an amazing role.
I'm begging.
I will sign your poster after.
I promise.
Thank you.
Hey!
Hi.
How are you?
I'm good.
Good.
This is one of the
students that I've
been working with this year.
She has an amazing voice.
Thank you.
So last night you sang a
song from the perspective
of a daughter whose mother is
a performer who is always away.
And you mentioned kind of
your goal to not be that way.
So I'm just curious, kind of a
personal question, how do you
and your husband make that
not happen and make sure
that that's not how
your children feel?
Mike is right there.
He actually is.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm sure you're both
wonderful parents.
What's it like from
your perspective?
Oh, it's like a
Chinese jigsaw puzzle.
I don't know.
We just sit down and
have planning meetings.
You're going to
this soccer lesson.
And I'm going to rehearsal.
And you have to work this day.
It's a bit like air
traffic control.
That's a better metaphor.
But I mean, Will and I, it's not
like we go out and party a lot.
If we're not working,
we're really with the kids.
But we also make
certain choices,
like we don't really audition
for TV shows that shoot in LA
so that we can be home.
For a lot of actors, that would
minimize a whole lot of work.
And years ago, it certainly
did, because there
wasn't a lot of film and
television in New York.
A lot of it was all LA,
and that's slowly changing.
But yeah, absolutely.
And it is a lot of planning and
one foot in front of the other
as each day goes.
But literally, when we're not
working, we're with the kids.
And I mean, there's no
children present right now.
Actually one is here.
One did a tour of MIT today.
Yeah, so maybe I'll be
giving the rest of the award
right back to MIT.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
1632 01:14:23,657 -->
01:14:24,240 You know what?
Here's the thing.
You commit to finding
a way to make it work.
And you commit to being as good
a parent as you possibly can.
And then you prioritize.
And so it's like it's
work or the kids,
and if they have other
plans, then we'll sneak away.
But other than that,
it's work or the kids.
Yeah, that's it.
Thank you.
You can do it!
But take your time.
Could we get a microphone over--
oh, there we go.
Thank you.
Hello, how are you?
Nice to see you.
It's good to see you.
I'm wondering-- you
received this phone call
from the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology
to be told that you're going
to get a McDermott Award.
And did you think they got the
wrong number, first of all?
I'm just wondering if you could
tell us what surprised you
about the residency?
What surprised you about the
students and the faculty?
What was your experience?
You hear MIT, and if you're
as intelligent as I am,
which is not much
intelligence, but I
had a preconceived
idea or notion of what
the students would be like.
And I was telling Talia
this-- the student that I had
the interview with--
I was telling or this earlier.
They've all
got their heads in books.
Or they're blowing up
things in a science lab.
What could
I possibly teach them?
And are they even
going to be interested?
And what I discovered
is these kids are--
not only they do not have
their heads in books,
and that's a lot of it,
because they have to.
But they are wide eyed and
curious and precocious.
And they seem to be full of joy.
And what I got a sense
for all that was like--
does this make sense?
This is what I feel when
I think about these kids I
see them reaching and arms
open and wanting to discover.
And so for me, coming in
to spend time with them
and talk to them and the few
master classes that I gave
or helping, they were just
sponges full of joy and wonder.
And I always felt
very hopeful when
I left that if these kids
want to, not only figure out
how to get us to Saturn,
cure cancer, and sing
an aria all in one day, if
they want to do it, they can.
They can.
Yeah, it was very inspiring.
[APPLAUSE]
And what
I saw from the faculty
is that they give them
the support and the space.
And what I
didn't expect but what
I was thrilled to see is
that there's a warmth that
comes from the faculty--
the faculty that I've spent--
there's a warmth
and a genuine caring
that they have for
their students.
And that filled me with
a great deal of hope,
especially like watching the
way Laura works with her kids.
You can tell she loves each and
every one of those kids so much
and is there for
them and support.
So especially as a
mom, two of our oldest
are going off to
college in a year,
to know that you could send
your kids to a place like this
or wherever you go,
and there's going
to be the support and warmth and
love as well as the knowledge
that they need.
I was inspired.
I'm a convert.
[LAUGHTER]
If I can just add, I
came here last night.
I was in Vancouver speaking
at the Ted Conference.
And I'm surprised
anybody is here,
because it felt like the entire
MIT faculty was presenting
at the Ted Conference.
But the kind of
technological genius
that I was hearing
over the past few days
in Vancouver, the idea
that can be coupled
with an understanding
of the importance of art
and the importance of
what culture means,
not just in general, but
particular to research,
particularly the idea of
science and advancement.
Some of you are old
enough to remember
CP Snow's The Two Cultures.
The more that we can get
the culture and the science,
the technology, and the
art to speak to each other,
the more likely we are to have
a world that we want to live in.
[APPLAUSE]
1734 01:19:17,074 -->
01:19:19,510 Hello.
Hi.
I loved, in the video reel,
hearing you talk about
if there's a role or something
that you're scared of that you
have to do it, because
it'll make you better,
even if it's not successful.
So I was wondering if
there was a time that
came to mind that you can
think of when you were working
through that, where you were
doing something you were scared
of and then maybe
wasn't as successful
as you would have hoped.
And what would you say
to somebody who might
be in that space right now?
I would say to you.
Wait, come here.
Don't go away.
Where are you going?
Come here.
[LAUGHTER]
No, I mean, you don't
have stand back up there.
I just wanted to get
out the spotlight.
That's all.
Ask and leave.
I would say don't be
afraid of failure.
The failure is part of
the learning experience.
And I failed on a daily basis.
On a daily basis, you fail.
If you succeed at
everything, you
won't ever grow, because
you won't ever learn.
I firmly believe that.
I'll be personal.
Let me give you an example.
As recently as yesterday,
I was scared to death
to do Laura's piece
at the concert
last night, because we had
only rehearsed it once.
And I felt like, I don't want
to let Laura down and not
do it here.
This is her home.
This is where she's teaching.
This is where the kids are.
And this is where I
learned the piece.
But I'm not ready,
and I'm scared.
And so at the point
in the concert
when it was time to do it,
I turned to the pianist,
and he said, "Do
you want to do it?"
And I said, "I'm gonna mess up."
And he was like,
OK, and he started
to turn the page
to the next song.
And then I thought, you're
scared, you need to do it.
And I turned back to him
and I said, "Let's do it."
So last night.
And I get it all right.
I mean, some of the
kids that know it,
I messed up on a
lot of the lyrics,
but oh, well, sorry, Laura.
I'll get it right by May 1st.
I will.
But it doesn't matter.
But I'm glad I did it.
And I learned, and I fell
a little bit on my face.
And you know what?
And so instead of just hiding
all that from the audience,
I told the audience like,
"I've rehearsed this once.
I need to do it.
Let's see what happens."
And I said to the
kids, "If I mess up,
shout out the words to me.
We'll get through it."
So fail every day.
You'll learn something.
[APPLAUSE]
Now you can go.
Hey.
Hi.
First of all, I want
to say thank you,
because when I was
in seventh grade
I saw you in Porgy
and Bess in New York,
and that's probably 90% of the
reason why I started singing.
Oh, my goodness.
And then my question
is, as a singer
who mainly has
classical training,
I was wondering if you
have any tips for expanding
to other vocal genres without
losing touch with my own voice.
Sing what you love.
Does that make sense?
I mean, sometimes at home I'm
singing Earth, Wind, and Fire.
I love Earth, Wind, and Fire.
And so it's coming from a
place of joy in my heart.
I mean, you fancy yourself
a singer absolutely, right?
It's a part of who you are.
So if you sing from
a place of love
and sing from a place of
something that you want
and that gives you
joy, just do it.
The only thing I
would say is, as long
as you're singing with your
voice, that's all that matters.
Don't try and be anybody else.
I don't sing Earth, Wind,
and Fire like Philip Bailey.
I wish I could sing like
Philip Bailey, but I don't.
I mean, we sing in
the same octave,
because he sang very high.
But I sing like me.
So I'm bringing my own
interpretation to it.
But I love it, and
I want to sing it,
and I have something to
say about that music,
about "September Song" or
"Got to Get You Into My Life,"
whatever.
It doesn't matter that I'm
singing it with my voice.
So stick with your own voice,
but sing what you want.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
You were
at the lunch too.
Yes, yes, you're back lit.
Now I see your face.
Hi.
Did we had like
flan or something
when we had the lunch?
Creme brulee.
The creme brulee, that's right.
Yes, yes, yes.
Hello.
Hi.
I was wondering-- so
like [INAUDIBLE] research
like your roles and stuff.
And a lot of them like have
a lot of historical context
and all that.
I remember my high school
did Ragtime my freshman year.
So the soundtrack to
that was where I first
learned about you.
And it was amazing.
So I was wondering when
you do all your research
and you have all the
context and the background,
how do you balance
that information
with your own
interpretations when
you're performing the roles?
How do I balance
all the information
from all the research
that I've done
with my own interpretation?
Yeah, like how you insert
yourself into the role.
The research is
there to support you.
You know what I mean?
But in the end, the role has
to be filtered through you.
So you take that
research, and it's there,
and it's there to
support you as you then
plug it into your own soul.
And then in the end, you
can't take all those books
and recordings and everything
out on the stage with you.
You go, "All right.
I am a play Billie Holiday,
but let me show you
how I swear this is right.
Check this out."
In the end, that's why I'm
saying, when I said to him,
you've got to throw
it all out the window.
It's there to support
you in that phase of it,
but then at the end, you
throw it out the window.
And then it's how it then
filters through yourself.
So in the end, it
does become up to you,
and it becomes a
part of who you are.
I would imagine--
I don't know about the
sciences-- but I would imagine,
in some way, you can
look at all the research,
but then you have to come
to your own conclusion
about what all the
research is showing you.
It has to be your
conclusion in the end.
So I think maybe it's the same.
Thank you.
I don't know.
[APPLAUSE]
So Audra, first, congratulationn
the 2018 Eugene McDermott
Award in the arts at MIT.
You're spectacular.
You've honored us.
And you brought Oskar with
you to double honor us.
And the two of you are
phenomenal together.
And you could see this
audience just deeply
appreciates what you've done
for us on this occasion.
Thank you so much.
And please stay close to us.
I will.
Both of you.
We will.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Well done.